first of all let me say i'm just
delighted to be here today
to talk with you a little bit about the
the low cost challenge
i think the first thing to to say is
this whole market for good enough
products and services saw that low
prices or even free and in some cases
is really growing in many industries
i've just listed a few industries there
but today it's almost hard to think of
an industry where low cost competition
is not a major challenge for the the
leading or premium players in that
particular industry
but we look at things like airlines i.t
services software electronic products
financial services chemicals
pharmaceuticals and so on it's
everywhere around us
i think the first thing to point out of
course is that low-cost competition
uh does not necessarily mean low profits
for the companies that are playing that
kind of game
with the right business model low-cost
companies can be very profitable and can
create high shareholder value
i've just given one example of this
today is from the airline industry
this is a
graph of some of the major airlines in
europe and north america all of the
major ones really
with their market capitalization in
billions of dollars
and maybe not surprisingly the most
valuable the company with the largest
market cap is delta airlines
but perhaps some big surprise to many of
you might be the one with the second
larger car
the second largest market cap is ryanair
this is by many standards a small
airline it's a low cost player in the
europe european region
its average ticket sells for about 45
euros that's its average fare around 60
at current exchange rates
it has annual revenues of about 6
billion
6 billion dollars u.s just less than 6
delta on the other hand which has a
marginally higher market market cap has
revenues of 37 billion move cancer has
revenues similar to delta so here you
have this small
regional airline
very very successful low-cost player
many people consider it best in class in
almost any industry highly profitable
and creating a lot of shareholder value
over the years
but for many of you i think the uh the
competition
from low-cost players
is not coming out of it could be coming
from the u.s or europe but for many of
you the challenges are coming from
developing countries in asia
particularly obviously china and india
and i'd argue that these tweeters can
represent a serious long-run challenge
because first of all
for many industries they have huge local
markets
i think we all know some of the the
figures on china but it is today
the largest car market in the world it's
the largest market for wind turbines
largest cement market in the world
largest for mobile phones cigarettes
telecommunications equipment and on and
on we moved to india india is the
world's largest tractor market for
example
and particularly in china many of these
local markets are highly competitive so
the companies that grew up in them
are developed their strategies in an
intensely competitive and innovative
local market where they compete not only
with many other local players
but also with many of the world's
leading multinationals who of course
these days can't afford not to be in
china
and the worry of course is if we let
these low-cost players win in a market
like china
where the local market might be 30
percent of the global market or 50 of
the global market or so on
they may have unbeatable economies of
scales and low costs by the time they
appear in developed markets
and in fact what we often see happen of
course
is that these local players in a country
like china they first emerge in what we
often call the good enough segment of
the market
the lower tier of the market where they
produce products or services to provide
basic functionality they're safe
and acceptably reliable and usually have
some basic level of service and support
usually just in the local market
whereas of course most of the leading
european and north american players tend
to compete more in the premium area of
the market and one of the things we see
for a period of time is often the growth
rates in the good enough segment of the
market are sometimes even multiples of
the growth rates at the premium end of
the market so this is an example from
low voltage frequency converters in
in china between 2004 and 2008
where the premium market was growing at
nine percent a year
but the good enough segment the market
was growing at 25 percent of year
and so these companies that successfully
compete in the good enough segment of
the market benefit from a very strong
tailwind
in terms of the fast growing segment as
well as they gain share in their own
market
segment so they grow very very rapidly
and of course
this good enough segment of the market
shown here in red and picking the case
of china
um
intensely competitive it's not in common
in things like wind energy or
we just talked about frequency
converters for there to be 50 to 100
local competitors competing in the good
enough segment of the market
so not surprisingly some of the better
of these local players really want to
move
up in towards the more premium segments
of the market
where they see as competition as being
less intense and of course margins look
particularly attractive
so we see them start to move up
at the same time in many cases they
start to move
into other parts of the developing world
perhaps in other countries in asia
africa
central and south america and so on
and over time of course they start to
move up in these markets as well
and then finally of course
they end up in the developed world and
by develop world i mean western europe
the united states
japan korea and so on um and so they
again will start to move up in that
segment of the market as well
and what we have to remember is that in
many cases
this
movement
of these low-cost competitors
is helped and encouraged and supported
by western suppliers and customers
so if for example you are intel
or qualcomm or ti or somebody like that
in the electronics industry
these let's say chinese customers are
perhaps your fastest growing customers
in the world and you want to help them
to succeed
so you provide them with reference
designs technical support in some case
support that goes into areas like
marketing strategy development and so on
and the and as they're working with
suppliers like intel ti
um qualcomm and so on
uh they also pick up
neither directly or indirectly some of
the experience from some of the these um
suppliers other customers around the
world
and so they they benefit from the
experience of
other customers other competitors in
europe or north america and so on
and of course the same thing happens
with customers
customers want their suppliers to
more competition
among their suppliers so they're welcome
the emergence of low-cost asian
competitors with good products and
services
and of course they might help those
suppliers as well with
with advice on what product
specifications would be best for the
north american market or the european
market or so on
in fact i mentioned a little bit earlier
one of the markets where china has is
particularly dominant is the cement
market
uh where in recent years it's accounted
for about 50 percent of the cement
production in the world
so not surprisingly chinese suppliers
have grown up that will build equipment
for some implants in fact will provide
turnkey cement plants the biggest of
these companies is a company called cbmi
until around five years ago cbmi was so
totally preoccupied with growth in the
chinese market it did very little work
outside of china but in the last five
years it started to move outside of
china and today
it has worked with some of the world's
leading cement manufacturers companies
like lafarge
wholesome
heidelberg cement italicimenti and so on
and of course if you're a lafarge and
you are having cbmi build
a
cement factory let's say for north
africa you want that cement factory and
the equipment in that cement factory to
be the highest quality
and to be very reliable
so what do you do well what you do is
you perhaps hire some retired engineers
from leading cement manufacturing
equipment companies in
canada or the
in
us canada europe
and ask them
to
hire them on a contract and send them
off to china to work in cbmi's factory
and of course these engineers as they're
working there
uh
pass on tips about maybe if you heat
treat this particular part this way
it'll be more reliable less less wear
things are labs on and so a lot of the
experience
that has been developed over dozens of
years decades perhaps
in
north american or european companies
gets passed on to the chinese and they
upgrade upgrade that manufacturing
processes very quickly
similarly when the cement plant is being
erected in north africa the same sort of
process goes on
you would gain maybe higher fuel a fire
some retired
project engineers that have
installed cement plants around the world
for meeting westing manufacturers
you have them and they are on site in
let's say in tunisia where you're
building a new cement factory and again
this supervised the construction of the
of the plant
and make sure as much as best as they
can that it's up to
leading world standards
so with what the result of all of this
is that over a period of time
very short period of time really these
chinese companies become competitive
with the very very best in the world
partly by their own efforts but partly
by a lot of help from their customers
and their suppliers
and of course this can sometimes lead to
fairly explosive growth
i think many of the people listening
today are undoubtedly aware of huawei
which competes in a number of areas but
uh certainly in the in communications
things like mobile communications
obviously routers and switches and
stones and equipment like that
huawei was really largely operating just
in china until about 1997 1998 where it
started to move out of china into
vietnam
russia
then it moved into africa
starting to put in much of the mobile
infrastructure in africa which of course
didn't have much of a fixed line
infrastructure
then moved on to south america
and then with the emergence of 3g
technology got some early contracts in
the gulf
and from there it also managed to get a
contract in the netherlands for its
first 3g installation in the netherlands
not with the leading dutch player but
with the the number new to a number
three player in the netherlands but
which was soon acquired by
the largest touch player and pretty soon
it became a major supplier to many of
the leading european uh carriers
from there of course it's now on its uh
last leg of its journey tried to move uh
into north america it does have some
contracts in the u.s and canada
but so far its growth in the u.s has
been
relatively slow
partly as many of you will be aware over
the last few months
in front of congress concerns about
security
if we have huawei
equipment in critical parts of our
telecommunications and communications
infrastructure
in north america
so here we have a company that really
started to move significantly
outside of china in 2004 there was a
really a very small country there with
sales revenues of about four billion
dollars
ericsson the largest player in in many
of these same competing infrastructure
areas at that time had sales of about 18
billion dollars
but we can see in a very very short
period of time
uh huawei has
caught up to erickson
and although it's
2012 the order drip figures have not
been produced yet
um there is every indication that in in
2012 it had sales in excess of 35
billion dollars passing ericsson to be
the global leader
in many parts of this telecommunications
infrastructure space
so very very quick
uh rapid growth once it emerged from
china
really
become a world contender so even as
early as 2009
fast company was was
was touting huawei as one of the five
most innovative companies in the world
after facebook amazon apple and google
and as early as 2009 it was winning its
first contracts
in norway and sweden
with tylenol and tele2
and so it's having a very strong
presence as early as 2000 that night in
the home market of ericsson
so this is the this is the nightmare
scenario for a country like a company
like ericsson these um relatively small
players emerge from china or perhaps
india
and soon become major significant
players on the world stage
of course some of us some leaders in
companies like ge like jeff involved are
just
really extremely worried about the
threats a company like huawei could
pause for a company like general
electric
as jekyll said a couple of years ago
jihi has tremendous respect for
traditional rivals like siemens phillips
and ross rice
but we know how to compete with them
they will never destroy us however the
emerging giants very well could
other executives though still seem to be
a little complacent
they don't take the threat from low-cost
competitors seriously
here's a quote from a couple of years
ago from the head of daimler trucks
if someone else says he wants to become
number one in the truck market above 14
tons
then i don't take them seriously because
he will not be able to succeed
they are selling trucks in china that
will that would have been sold in here
in europe 40 years ago
when we look at some of the facts about
the chinese truck market
many of us would get a little concerned
three of the five largest truck makers
in the world by volume
are chinese
china accounted for 50 of all truck
sales in 2010
and china truck makers are already
expanding very aggressively in southeast
asia north africa and the middle east
in fact very much following the same
path that huawei took to its uh global
leadership position
and of course
the complacency we see from this
tarantula perhaps comes from feeling
that perhaps
these chinese players will have to
follow the same popular daimler trucks
as has taken over the years and so will
take them many many years perhaps even
decades to catch up with uh with timer
however as we all know there are a
number of shortcuts
so fairly recently this year
there was an announcement that volvo
had
was setting up a joint venture in china
with one of the leading um
chinese truck manufacturers dongfeng
motor group
uh and was investing uh about a billion
dollars in that in joint venture
and of course this would give don thing
access to volvo
as technology involved was distribution
channels bobo also
makes
mac trucks in in north america
so here clearly dong thing now has
some shortcuts as it tries to achieve
this global leadership
and what we argue more generally is that
the world has changed in the last 10 or
20 years
the
barriers to entry have come down
dramatically in many industries making
it much easier for low-cost competitors
to glow to grow and flourish
so getting to good enough quality in
many industries is today relatively easy
and of course there are large and
growing segments of customers in many
markets for business to customer
consumer and business for business that
is satisfied with good enough products
and services
and one of the reasons these barriers to
entry have come down is that new
business models have emerged
that help these new players become
effective competitors with
industry leaders
so let's spend a couple of minutes just
talking a little bit about that
what we see in many industries
is that
highly focused players have emerged in
the last 10 to 20 years
so if we think back
20 years ago and in many
companies many industries even today
many of the companies are what we might
call a traditional business model so
we're thinking of companies here like
intel procter gamble caterpillar and so
on
if we think of most businesses have
three core processes to do with
innovation
where we design
and develop innovative products and
services for our customers
infrastructure where we make those
products and services for our customers
or if we're a telecom carrier we have
the infrastructure to deliver our
services to our customers
and then thirdly customer relationships
where we build and maintain
relationships with customers
so if we think of companies like intel
png and caterpillar traditionally they
tended to do all of these things
themselves
but what we've seen in particularly in
the last 10 20 years depending on the
industries we've seen some companies
emerge
that are much which have much more
focused business models
good local example for those of you in
the bay area of course would be a
company like cisco
that really almost from its beginning
was very much focused on customer
relationships
clearly it did some fundamental
innovation when it started up
but most of the innovation the
revolutionary innovation since its
startup
has occurred by making acquisitions
of other
companies
right from the beginning most of its
manufacturing was outsourced to third
parties so it's it was um so it really
focused on the customer relationship
aspects of the business and in a sense
it outsourced its innovation and
infrastructure activities
another company that's moved more in
that direction over the year would be
dell computers clearly dell has never
done much fundamental innovation in
terms of computers much of that is done
by suppliers again companies like intel
nvidia ti national semiconductor before
it was part of ti and the thousands of
other people microsoft hardware and
software people that design
uh developed uh products for the pc
industry the sort of the business and so
on
and so and most recently of course dell
has basically got out of any sort of
manufacturing activity even final
assembly now is basically
everything is basically outsourced
it doesn't mean that dell doesn't do
some innovation doesn't have an
infrastructure but a lot of dell's
innovation has been focused on
how to do that customer relationship
activity better particularly using the
internet
to service
to sell and service the equipment itself
it also of course has a massive i.t
infrastructure
to support all of its uh all of its
activities
another company that's moved very much
in the customer relationship area from
having a traditional business model
would be ibm global services
clearly ibm global service is now a big
part of ibm it's very much a customer
relationship business
and then of course we have some other
companies
that have chosen to focus on the
innovation business
one we see in the bay area and really
all around the world today of course
would be in the biotech technology
industry where a lot of the fundamental
innovation
in the pharmaceutical biotechnology is
done by
literally thousands of startup companies
who are looking for the next big
breakthrough and treating something like
a particular form of cancer or something
like that
clearly if one of these companies is
successful
it typically has no manufacturing
infrastructure to make the product it
has developed in fact it probably
doesn't even have the infrastructure to
do the clinical trials
and certainly it doesn't have a customer
relationship a sales and marketing
organization around the world to sell
this new
new drug this new treatment globally so
what do they do well typically of course
they either sell out to a large
pharmaceutical company like pfizer
or roche or novartis or
astrazeneca or somebody like that
another one a company many of you will
be familiar with in the in the bay area
would of course be arm holdings
this is of course a uk company that has
become very very prominent in the in the
last few years
what um holdings does is just
microprocessor designs
for
everything from
mobile phones setup boxes digital
cameras
and on and on and on gps navigators and
so on
it's that company that just does the
design
it uh licenses the technology to
customers and receives the royalty
payment every time the chip is made the
chip very well may be formed by somebody
like tsmc in taiwan
the customer might be a company like
apple that uses
um chips or arm cores basically in its
ipods iphones even its ipads although it
does some further um design work on top
of the um holding core
core processor
and of course so arm holdings has this
really intellectual property business
last year it um there are about 8.7
billion of its designs used in products
around the world
it makes perhaps less than 10 cents per
chip
for each design that is used but that
gave us a uh
revenues of over 800
million dollars last year in
intellectual property revenue which
should then of course plowed right back
into uh r d
to
develop
and advance its um its microprocessor
designs
and going back to our friends at daimler
trucks the same sort of thing exists
in many many other industries we have
people
like
um holdings
and so on that will sell their latest
designs to anybody in the world whether
it be a nokia an apple or a startup in
china
in the heavy truckee drone
heavy
duty commercial vehicle of this business
we have companies like ricardo
an english engineering company
an english-based european-based
engineering consulting company
that does again
will work for anybody that has a very
difficult engineering problem
porsche engineering is another one
ricardo works with for companies uh like
um bmw
general motors
navistar and so on
and of course it's seen the emergence of
these vehicle manufacturers in china and
india and so in its 2010 annual report
it noted that in china and india
construction vehicle manufacturers are
reaching a critical size the point at
which developing their own driveline
components becomes a viable alternative
to purchasing from europe or the us
several are now seeking to acquire the
key ricardo technologies that will
enable them to compete on a global basis
so unlike daimler
trucks
these emerging chinese manufacturers or
indian manufacturers like qatar
do not need to develop everything
themselves they can link up with a
ricardo or with a porsche engineering
and
get and get much of the expertise that
these companies have developed by
working with some of the countries that
the world's leading heavy-duty vehicle
manufacturers
and of course the um
the third leg of the um of the
of these focused business models are the
infrastructure players
so today in the electronics industry of
course many of our electronic uh
products
are manufactured in the asia it's clue
obviously for many other kinds of
products and services as well
and there we have companies like horn
high
which goes under the trade name of
foxconn
that
manufactures mobile phones for companies
like
motorola
nokia
um many many of the chinese
manufacturers makes ipad ipods iphones
for apple
it makes um
september set up boxes for a number of
manual a number of players makes skin
machines from nintendo and sony and so
on and so on
as many of you know it has one
manufacturing facility in shenzhen
which has ha which has
books has had up to 300 000 people
working in this one
city just down the road actually from
huawei which is also headquartered in
shenzhen
so you have 300 000 people assembling uh
manufacturing and assembling this
variety of products for many of the
leading electronics menu companies in
the electronics manufacturing companies
in the world
and
and of course
one has to wonder a little bit about why
would apple work with somebody like on
high
um why and the answers i think fairly
obvious first of all
hon hai has massive scale
it's a very low cost producer but
perhaps most more importantly for
apple is it has a very very high quality
so it does a lot of innovation on high
but a lot of in its innovation is
process innovation about how to
how to make products
more quickly more reliably at lower cost
with better quality and so on
and last but not least and perhaps most
important for apple by working with hon
hai it gets tremendous flexibility
the summers anniversary may remember
three years ago
in march just before the launch of the
ipad in april 2010
analysts were having difficulty
estimating the potential market size for
ipods
and analysts projections for the market
for ipad just prior to the launch in
april 2010 was ipad apple might sell 1
million ipads in 2010
or 9 million ipads in 2010.
so if you're apple how much if you were
building this these ipads himself how
build a bigger facility do you build if
you build for 1 million and sales are 10
million or potential sales of 10 mini
you have a
massive
um
stock out problem if you build for 10
million and it's only 1 million then you
have massive capital that's being
dramatically underutilized but by
working with horn high on high can
rapidly
scale and ramp up production to meet the
needs of the customer
so
and that gives tremendous flexibility to
a company like apple and the other
companies that work with with on high
so when you look at these three focused
business models infrastructure
innovation customer relationships
the key success factors in these
businesses are somewhat different in an
infrastructure business it's about scale
it's about being large enough
to be
a low-cost producer to have world-scale
efficiencies
in an innovation company it's very much
about time to market and timing we want
to be first to market without for a
biotechnology company with a particular
breakthrough for a particular form of
cancer
um because the first person the first
company to bring it to market will
probably
be able to sell the company or license
the technology at the highest price
if we're a customer relationships
company
a lot the key success factor is built
around scope by scope we mean once we
have built a relationship with a
customer
we want to amatize the cost of building
and maintaining that relationship over
as many products and services as
possible so we amatize the
the cost of building and maintain the
relationship over a relatively high
sales volume
so the focus of these companies tends to
be a little different a hon hai is very
much focused on costs
as we know from silicon valley many of
the more innovation focus companies are
very focused on attracting the best and
the brightest people
and the times we see the perks and so on
to attract the dresden and brightest
people so get a little out of whack when
we have dog walking services and things
of that sort that are popped toy budgets
and things of that thought that pop up
in silicon valley from time to time
and on the customer relationship and
ship aside companies like cisco are
intently focused on customers
so before the rise of telepresence and
similar services uh john chambers used
to personally visit the ceos
of 30
existing or prospective customers every
month
so he glowed globetrotted around the
world meeting customers and potential
customers
every night reputedly before he went to
bed he wanted updates on the 10 most
critical system
cisco accounts
from the account managers so clearly
john chambers and cisco very very
focused on their customers
now if you think about it it becomes
quite difficult to optimize on costs
people and customers in one organization
so one of the arguments is
it might be better we might be better
off if we have an absolutely world-class
customer relationship company
that works with or acquires
best-in-class innovation companies and
works in
best-in-class infrastructures
infrastructure companies
it doesn't mean as a company like cisco
once we've acquired a business we don't
continue to do the evolutionary uh
innovation but maybe for the
revolutionary staffs we still look for
acquisitions to acquire that kind of
technology
one of the benefits of using this this
alliance if you like of customer
relationship innovative and
infrastructure best in class companies
is
sometimes speed that sometimes we can
move very very quickly i'll just say one
quick example of that from the us market
that many of you will be familiar with
visio
which
makes large screen
lcd
tvs for example
makes other things now as well but
that's where that was where its initial
was
because recently uh
of course as recently as 2004 that vizio
had sales of 20 million dollars and had
six
employees by 2006 to sorry 2007 it had a
market share in the us of 12.4 percent
sony that year had 12.5
and samsung had 14.2
by 2009
it was the market leader with a with a
share in the u.s market of about 19
and vizio very much
follows this partnership market it has
um some very strong relationships
including some equity with contract
manufacturers in taiwan and china
including hong hai is one of the smaller
investors in it and of course it has
access to uh innovation from companies
like um holdings dolby and so on
so with with that kind of business model
that's been able to grow very very
rapidly and be quite successful in the
market
unless we just think this is a first
world phenomena it isn't
we see some of the leading players
in asia also taking advantage of some
aspects of this these focused business
models obviously the intellectual
property and so on here's a good example
from india india bodhiatel
this uh it's from a couple of years ago
when
party passed its 100 millionth customer
at that point it was adding customers as
the rate of 35 million
per year
so growing very very rapidly
in in the market and again it's very
much body is a customer relationship
company
it's it's um its mobile phone
infrastructure is largely outsourced to
ericsson
and nokia season siemens two-thirds of
india
uh the infrastructure is designed and
put in place by and operated by um nokia
siemens
sorry by eriksen and one-third by nokia
siemens all of its i.t infrastructure
including billing systems etc is
provided by ibm global services so if
you have a quote-unquote
developing country company working with
absolutely best-in-class developed
country partners
to succeed in the indian market
and as those of you that have spent much
time in india know this is the most
competitive mobile phone market in the
world average
cost per minute is about 1 usm per
minute pricing is on a per second basis
and
until in 2010 the last year that party
xl basically only operated in india
it had revenue
revenues of about 8.8 billion
and net income of 2 billion so here
again is a low cost competitor
very successful and at that time very
profitable competing in a very very
tough market
so what we've said here today is that
these networks of highly focused parents
are really challenging traditionally
organized companies
they focus on particular core processes
where they have the potential to become
best in class and they work with other
companies
that are best in class and their core
process so the alliance that network can
sometimes compete very very effectively
with traditionally horizontally
integrated companies
and of course many but obviously not all
low-cost competitors benefit from the
press presence of these best-in-class
highly focused players
so in summary
um i think
we see from a demand side
there are
many customers
in
in most markets that are looking for
good enough products and services
and there are companies that are willing
to provide those good enough products
and services many of them coming from
asia but not necessarily from asia
so you should not be tempted to ignore
the threat from these competitors based
in the good enough segments of the
market
because you don't lose much business to
them initially
over time they can totally disrupt the
market as we see with a company like
ryan
as we see with a company like huawei
we do on the positive side have of
options as a premium pair for how to
respond to the threat of these low-cost
competitors i think it's absolutely
critical that we recognize the challenge
early and respond proactively
uh you can never move too quickly
to complete the low-cost threat
when we come back on the next weather
now we will have an opportunity to talk
about three winning options
for
dealing with and responding to the
low-cost challenge
so let me hand it back over to tom
all right all right once again thank you
adrian and we're going to come back to
you and do some q a here in just a few
minutes and
appreciate ryan positioning who is
sponsoring not only today but
all this professional education
opportunities throughout the year i
i
again in the
lucky to be the academic co-director of
the stanford executive institute which
will take place here
in august it's a residential program so
you come and
uh
be with us along with adrian and um 10
other faculty so there's uh adrian
myself and
ten faculty that are all very senior
educators very comfortable with
technology very comfortable
with um
teaching executives that that's why
we choose them i
look this is a very
good time to be a leader and a manager
of a either a tech based company or a
tech intensive company i'm an enterprise
in other words some enterprise trying to
to grow
and
succeed in their markets it's very
challenging though i mean every sector
is
undergoing tremendous disruption
every business is global
every solution requires innovation like
uh
adrian was talking about you know
frankly both in the in their
technologies uh for the products and
services as well as their business
models
and they better develop uh basically
just thinking about the global thing
they better develop uh very very good
alliances this is the stuff that we
stress this
during that week with adrian and the 10
other faculty
great general managers have got to be
leaders right now
and that means being able to craft a
tangible vision and strategy like adrian
was talking about in his particular uh
case
it's understanding of the fundamentals
of finance and accounting the language
of business in other words
and
last but not least it's the ability to
turn groups into effective teams um you
know managed by mutual influence not
coercion and authority like our parents
used to do or um
you know foster and foster overall a
culture of experimentation so it's been
my pleasure
to
assemble
teachers frankly that i am in awe of as
i mentioned and i've been doing this as
the witness program since 1995 since
coming back from silicon valley industry
to academic life the program actually
has routes to 1975 when the electronics
industry was just hitting its stride
here in silicon valley but here we are
we find ourselves almost 40 years later
with um
with an opportunity to learn together so
right here in silicon valley
um you know where companies continue to
scale and be admired around the world we
can bring together
a set of faculty
to
step through
this kind of material
in less than a week six days of
instruction
this faculty is the best of breed in any
given category of or this you know
finance or whether it's organizations or
whether it's uh strategy or for
marketing i i look we look for the very
very best of breed
they tend to have some sort of stanford
connection that's fine but we're not
limited to that you can tell
adrian is a professor emeritus of imd
for example and our finance professor is
that works with us is uh the author of
the all-time best-selling textbook in
finance and a professor at the
university of washington in seattle
again they all have experience with tech
companies or tech intensive companies
they're able to deliver their
their messages and key learnings in uh
three or so days they they come in and
out of the program over the six days and
they're layered that way
um and they we tend to use their
textbooks because they are the authors
of the of the leading textbooks or trade
books in the field
the morning sessions just to give you a
picture and this is all up on the
website by the way including the bios of
the folks i've been talking about
the morning sessions you can see are nba
style
instruction meaning we tend to use cases
it's
it's very experiential uh
with the traditional case method that
was popularized by harvard and stanford
and those kinds of schools over the
years
and then in the afternoons we're much we
go even deeper in experiential learning
with an innovation lab that we call the
new venture lab
um and uh with uh ceo uh
you know town hall meeting types things
and then evenings are spent in small
study groups with frankly folks from
another company
so it's an opportunity to work together
on getting ready for the next day
with some
other folks that are
facing similar challenges than you are
at the bottom line is we're trying to
help you become a t-shaped person that's
something we you say a lot here in
engineering school both in the design
and entrepreneurship centers and that is
you might have a depth of knowledge in a
particular discipline in fact you do you
would in order to get where you are in
your career but by stepping back
in for a week it might you know unchain
yourself to come in and get a breath of
uh
learning
well a breadth of understanding about
leadership general management innovation
uh all that
uh again and if not not only for that
week will stimulate you but then launch
you into the next phase of your career
so that's what we're after with this
all right so let's check in with uh
adrian do we have some uh
we have some questions that were
submitted terrific so uh first question
adrian is do you see a trend towards an
increase in international joint ventures
between domestic premium market based
firms and international low-cost rivals
um following on that how does the force
of rivalry weigh against the force of
joint collaboration
yeah that's a good question i'm not sure
i would see any trend
so
the one example we talked about there
was volvo and dongfeng obviously and
uh i see perhaps more more companies
really
there's less than seems to me less
emphasis for example in china on joint
ventures and more
efforts to uh on acquisitions
perhaps acquiring a low-cost chinese
player
there's some interesting challenges in
how you keep a low-cost chinese clear
low-cost chinese player when it's owned
by a european or north american country
or in some cases like abb recently wrote
a case on abb which is actually starting
which has recently started up at
low-cost chinese players try to
duplicate
a chinese player to
to be able to to compete in the good
enough segment market with a much lower
cost business model than its traditional
abb business
so um so i see that going on
all right i think we'll actually talk
about those examples perhaps a little
bit in the in the webinar coming up
because obviously that's one of the ways
to compete
exactly all right good uh let's do
number uh let's do a second one uh from
one of the participants that says uh
does this mean that going forward the
innovators in the developed world will
focus on value addition
and high-tech solutions while
manufacturers in the developing world
will buy their ideas and use them to
market end products to the mass market
with low cost manufacturing
um
yeah i don't think there's one i mean
it's again a good question i don't think
there's one example
because clearly we can see some some
very strong
american companies that are chosen
choosing to go in a totally different
way
for example intel intel is a company
that really is a company with a very
much a traditional business model it
does its own infrastructure it has its
own
customer relationships it does its own
innovations and in fact it's it sees
itself
as being able to compete more
effectively with focused competitors
like arm by keeping all of that in-house
so having its manufacturing forks work
with its r d as it absolutely pushes
the the state of the art in technology
so um
um i don't think there's anyone and it's
clearly what what solomon says is
we are seeing some of that going on but
i don't think there's a
one-size-fits-all answer for this
all right when and perhaps one more if
we can and we'll stay on schedule here
you you can't pick up uh
you know
well or read something about business
without reading about china it seems
like uh nowadays so we hear about
lately we hear a lot about labor storage
shortages and rising labor costs in
china um
and you talked about you know that may
the primary example there in shenzhen so
are chinese enterprises going to become
less of a low-cost challenge in the
future or more
um
yeah i don't certainly don't see the
threat going away
clearly labor costs are rising they're
rising quite rapidly
uh sorry um hon hai is one of the
companies being really impacted on that
one of its responses is
is investing very very heavily in
robotics and automation right now
so it is going to try to continue to
compete from china but using much more
highly automated factories
clearly
as
the chinese market is also growing so
it's continuing to be it's going to
continue to be a bigger part of the
global market for many products and
services so i think it's going to
continue to be a bit a major and major
part of it
a lot of the impacting can't bring
really be out to us because the supply
chains
are now heavily focused on asia it's
hard to imagine a lot of that moving
back to north america some will but not
a lot
all right thank you so much adrian and
thanks again for being part of our
teaching team here in august at the
stanford executive institute i'm looking
forward to welcoming you back to campus
at that time
you